a new timeline of the Dayton Ohio
Massacre provides chilling details about
the shooters movements this new
surveillance video shows the moments
before the gunman killed nine people in
a span of just 32 seconds ten days ago
26 others were wounded Dean Reynolds has
been following this story dean our
investigators any closer to learning a
motive here they are not Anthony they
have not yet established a motive but
they do believe that the gunman acted
alone his own sister was among the
victims but investigators remain divided
on whether he intentionally targeted her
two hours before beginning his violent
rampage 24-year old Connor Betts his
sister and a friend are seen on
surveillance video seemingly headed for
a night of bar-hopping their first stop
a place called blind Bob's just after
midnight Betts crosses the street and
heads to another bar separating from his
sister and friend at 12:42 wearing a
t-shirt and shorts he heads back to the
car Andrea merges in a hoodie body armor
and backpack waited by his weapon and
ammunition minutes later at 1:05 a.m.
the shooting begins the crowd on the
patio of a bar scatters the gunfire
lasts for 32 seconds before police stop
it that's his sister was shot to death
and his friend was wounded text messages
revealed Betts knew their location about
seven minutes before opening fire but
investigators say they can't agree
whether he targeted them summer saying
absolutely not he was not intentional
some say no it had to be I would say
it's inconclusive police say they
believe the shooters sister and friend
knew nothing about his violent
intentions that night and are still
searching for a motive I think we have a
lot of information about mindset I think
that should be enough somatically that
you get a pretty clear picture of what
was going on here
police say the gunman was very familiar
with the area and it's night spots and
was actually there on that street the
night before his rampage
Tony Dean Reynolds Forest Dean thank you
very much